I want to do now is start thinking about
ancient civilizations and we're going to
start with Mesopotamia and Mesopotamia
the word is literally referring to the
fact that this region is for the most
part between two rivers you have the
Tigris River and the Euphrates River and
when we talk about ancient Mesopotamia
most people are referring to the period
between around 3,000 BCE or maybe even
going a little bit before that so 3,000
before the Common Era and then going up
to about the time of Christ or a little
bit before that so we might go to a
thousand BCE or maybe a little bit later
maybe around 500 BCE and what I've done
here is we clearly have a map of the
region I also have timelines for
different different geographies so this
timeline that I have right here in blue
this is my timeline for Mesopotamia
Mesopotamia right over here and you can
see that I have different colors along
this timeline and you can also see what
other civilizations were around at the
at the same time in history and this is
not a comprehensive list year so what we
have in this yellow this is ancient
Egypt and you can see that them
sprouting out around the Nile it's no
coincidence that these are around rivers
the rivers flood and provide fertile
ground where you can have agriculture
where you can support population centers
so it's no coincidence that you have a
civilization around the Nile you have a
civilization in Mesopotamia between the
Tigris and Euphrates rivers so this is
the Egyptians right over here this is
ancient Mesopotamia right over here I
have the Indus Valley Civilisation and
then we have China and once again not
comprehensive we have other
civilizations going on but these are
ones that you will often hear being
spoken about now in Mesopotamia
especially when we're talking about
ancient Mesopotamia you will hear about
different groups and different languages
and so you'll hear about the Sumerians
oftentimes they are most famous today
for their cuneiform writing and we'll do
a whole probably a whole series of
videos as it's one of the
one of the original ways of symbolic
writing that the Sumerians developed you
might also hear about the Acadians
and the Acadians or both Acadian could
be referring to an actual Empire or it
could be referring to the Akkadian
language and same thing about Sumerian
you might hear about the Assyrians
Assyrians
you might hear about the Babylonians
Babylon Babylonians and all of these
groups are associated with Mesopotamia
the Sumerians lived generally in this
area right around here in a future of
video we might talk about Abraham from
the Old Testament is from or which is a
Sumerian city and Sumerian is also a
language and it's an it's an language
that's not related to the languages that
we now associate with the region or the
languages that were spoken by the
Acadians the Acadians so if we're
talking about languages that are similar
to modern spoken languages Acadian was a
Semitic language let me write that down
it was it was Semitic so Akkadian is
related to Arabic and Hebrew and if we
think about more ancient times Aramaic
Aramaic so all of these things were
related and the Assyrians and
Babylonians the they were Akkadian or
they spoke the Akkadian language or if
we go later on they spoke Aramaic but
they were in constant contact with the
Sumerians so they even have Akkadian
being written in a in a with a cuneiform
type of script and the general
geographies were these different
civilizations these different empires
sprung up from so you have Nineveh right
over here that is the historical capital
of the Assyrian Empire and on my little
line here and this isn't exact and we're
learning more and more about this time
period all of the time you
realize this we're talking about you
know 3000 BCE that's over 5,000 years
ago so we're still trying to put all the
puzzle pieces together but we believe
around 3,000 BCE there was a somewhat
unified Akkadian Empire then it started
to break up and split up at some points
you had the Assyrians you had the
Assyrians more or less in control of the
region at other points you had the
Babylonians with the capital at Babylon
and we'll talk about famous babylonian
kings like homer obby and nebuchadnezzar
and actually bable bable on gets
referred to a lot more but for most of
this time period we're talking about the
Assyrians were actually the dominant
Empire with their capital at Nineveh
Sumerian is from that was more often
part of these other empires and so this
is just a start to get us acquainted
with this region of the world with
Mesopotamia as we go off into the next
few videos we'll continue to dig deeper
we'll talk a little bit about we'll talk
more about the cuneiform writing we'll
talk more about who marabi and his
famous code of laws that seems to have
influenced the Old Testament we'll talk
more about Nebuchadnezzar in his role
and he actually has a role in in the Old
Testament as well and the interactions
between these different civilizations
and it gets quite interesting